Hi, good morning.
So how are things?
How was your first class?
Last week you had a whole day
class.
Lovely.
You'll get used to it.
OK, OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is.
Back to college days.
It's a full time program, right?
I mean, it's a degree and then.
Yeah, you had some questions I
hope says I had some questions.
Yeah, you can also put it in
that discussion in canvas if
it's something quick.
I can also take it up now.
Yes, yes, we'll do that.
Karthikeyan yeah.
So all my classes will have a
quick recap of what we did and
then we will get started with
the new topics.
Yep, primitive is really simple
now.
Yeah.
So it's all about the heart of
each statement.
Yeah.
So something like adding,
multiplying, assigning.
You know, things like that.
But there's an exhaustive list
also in your textbook given, but
as in, when you practice, you'll
get to know right in each
statement.
Yeah, sorting is not considered
primitive.
Yeah.
Because if you see about
sorting, there are a lot of
things happening inside sorting
right stack is not a.
Again, you know primitive
operation.
So inside stack, what happens?
There are a lot of things that
we can do, right.
Of course we have that in our
course.
We will look at that in detail,
but primitive is that is why the
other way of primitive is basic,
right?
It it is the most basic
operation, like very small
operations like assignment.
You know, taking a value
additions all basic operations,
arithmetic operations, right?
All such things are primitive.
I know we talk about sorting,
searching stacks, operations on
them and so on.
That is not actually primitive.
Yeah.
Does that help?
Yeah, you need to refer all, so
that is what I told in the first
class that go the extra mile
just being here and, you know,
having your, you know, slides or
book will not help you.
So please go ahead and that is
your first step attending the
class and also looking at your
you know textbook is your first
step but after that you can go
to the you know reference books,
other books and so on.
Yeah.
We will come to that Prakash
when the time comes, we will
look at those.
So we will have to again expand
that code and every line of it,
we will do the same thing.
Yeah, we will do that.
We'll have a quick walk.
Yeah, cool.
I think it's good time for us to
start.
It's 8:35.
We have waited for 5 minutes, so
let's quickly do that.
So for all these type of
questions please put it in our
discussion forum.
Yeah, that is the whole point of
that canvas discussion.
So in the class we'll just look
what these topics and on the way
we'll have some questions, but
all the, you know, other
questions that you have, you can
put it in our canvas discussion
and the TEAMS or me, one of us
will you know, reply to that and
that is also persisted there,
right?
So these calls, you know, it'll
get vanished, and these chats
will, you know, at the end of
your semester, they'll be like,
you know, 50,000 plus messages.
Yeah, you'll not even know what
was our tool replied and so on.
But in canvas it's all threaded,
so you'll be able to go back and
revise before your exams.
Yeah.
So please post questions there
as well.
They also just let me know once
the screen is visible.
Yes.
No, maybe.
Cool.
So welcome to the second contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design.
And today we will continue our
discussion on analyzing
algorithms.
Yeah.
So the agenda for today, we'll
have a quick recap of what we
did in the last class.
We will then have a quick look
of some general rules and myths
around, you know, this analysis.
Yeah.
And we'll also have a look at
how do you analyze algorithms
which are non recursive in
nature.
We also see what is recursion
and you know things like that.
And if it is a recursive
algorithm, how do we analyze it?
And then there's something
called as a master's theorem,
and we will have some examples
of them pull.
So let's go ahead and have a
quick recap.
Yeah.
So in the last class we got
started with.
What was this course about?
We'll, you know, spoke about the
textbooks course handout.
What is the program?
What is an algorithm?
And so on.
And then we also had a short
outlook of what we are going to
do in this semester, right.
So all the first few LECTURES,
right?
So the 1st 10 second class are
just motivation.
We just learned about what is
algorithms, what do we analyze
them and so on.
And today as well, we will do
the same thing, but from the
next class onwards from the
third class till your mid
semester exams, we will look at
data structures right.
There are plenty of data
structures in this field, but we
will just look at some important
ones like you know, array linked
list, stacks, queues, trees, AVL
trees, binary search trees and
so on.
Yeah.
And then we'll go for exams and
then we will then start
algorithm techniques.
Right.
We will learn about a lot of
algorithm techniques and in the
last two classes we will have a
look at those type of problems
that are still not solvable
efficiently, right.
There are a lot of still
challenging problems.
We are not able to solve them
efficiently even with all they
know AI way when advanced you
know hardware and so on.
Still, we are not able to solve
them efficiently.
We will look at those in the
last few classes, right?
So before that, we also looked
at all these, you know,
motivations for why do we do
algorithm analysis right?
So for example, if there are two
people who are solving a problem
right have given given a problem
and Prakriti solves it and
Surendran doesn't solve it, then
there is no point of even, you
know discussing an analysis or
anything.
We can directly tell that one of
them has solved it.
The other one has not solved it,
so this is the window.
But the whole problem starts
when all of them are solving it
correct?
So for example, if there is
sorting, there are 1020
algorithms which are doing
sorting correctly, right?
All of them are correct.
Then the question comes who's
better?
Who's performing well, right?
So that is where the whole field
of algorithm analysis comes into
picture.
OK.
Is it making sense for all of
you?
Yeah, that is the simplest form,
right?
I mean, all of these things are
working, so how do I know
something is better?
So I need to analyze them right?
So that is why algorithm
analysis is done and I'll go for
the best one when I implement
right.
And then we also looked at what
is that better?
Yeah, better means that it is
going to take less amount of
time and less amount of space.
And we also convinced ourselves
that, you know, this
experimental studies are not
very effective because if two
people are going to know, do
this experimental study, they
need to use the exact same
hardware, exact same software,
they need to first of all
implement that algorithm as a
program. Right?
Again, there is a problem.
Someone could write it in
assembly language.
Someone can write it in a high
level language.
They all are different in their
speeds, right?
Assembly language can quickly
talk to the hardware, but high
level language cannot do that
right?
So there are many you know, you
cannot compare an apple with an
orange, right?
So we should not do these
experimental studies unless we
have the exact same, you know,
infrastructure ready for us to
do.
So we told that we will use this
RAM model.
So this RAM model is nothing but
an imaginary machine, right?
So it's an imaginary machine
where there is a single
processor.
Each simple operation or a
primitive operation takes 1 unit
of time and loops and
subroutines are not simple
operations right?
Because they have code inside
them again, and each line is.
They might have primitive
operations.
We looked at all this and then
we had looked at the pseudo
code.
Yeah.
So what about others?
Are you able to hear me?
I see Santosh telling.
So whenever you see says
messages, you can just tell them
to, you know, quit and rejoin.
Yeah, they should be able to
hear.
But yeah, so then we spoke about
pseudo codes, right?
So why do we need this pseudo
code?
Yeah.
So the first problem was that we
need to communicate between
fellow programmers, right?
For example, I know Python, you
might know just Java, you might
know.
See programming.
I might not know that.
So how do we communicate
solutions then, right?
One way to do that is plain
English, right?
I can just write it in a
paragraph and you can just show
me that this is how I have
solved, but that is again a
problem because learn English
language will not actually
capture certain nuances of
programming.
Yeah. For example, assignment,
for example looping right?
So such things we will not be
able to capture well in an
algorithm or just by writing in
plain English, right?
You can still do that.
That is not wrong. Yeah.
So you can write it as step one,
Step 2, step three, Step 4.
You know things like that, but
that will be plain English and
that might cause some ambiguity.
So we wanted a middle ground and
that is what is a suedo code.
So in simple pseudo code is more
structured than English, but it
is less detailed than a program,
but definitely remember that if
you just type the pseudo code it
will not work.
Yeah, it's because this is not
any language at all, right?
This is language agnostic.
This is used just to communicate
between programmers and we will
also be able to analyze the sudo
code.
Yeah.
So we will be able to directly
identify the primitive
operations.
We will be able to, you know,
analyze them before even
implementing it.
So once you have written a seudo
code, you have actually solved
the problem.
You know the solution now?
Then you can translate it into
any language of your choice,
say.
Plus plus Java, Python,
whatever. Right.
Yeah, I'm doing a recap.
Yeah, we learned about all that.
And then we also looked at this
primitive operations will also
look at that today as well, but
counting primitives is a very
simple technique.
What you do is you just write
your code that is pseudo code
and then every line you start
inspecting what are the
primitive operations in it.
Yeah, assignment is a primitive
operation.
I reindexing is a primitive
operation.
Comparison is a primitive
operation.
Addition is a primitive
operation.
Return is a primitive operation,
right?
And there are some lines which
are inside a loop, right?
So I'll have to see how many
times that line will execute.
So this line has three primitive
operation, array indexing,
addition, assignment and this
line itself executes more than
one time, right?
Because it is in a loop, so I'll
calculate those.
I'll submit all that and I will
get something like this and then
we learned about a couple of
rules right there were these two
rules that I will drop the lower
order term and I will also drop
the constant multiplier.
The reason for doing that was we
convinced ourselves that always
we will do worst case analysis,
right.
We can analyze algorithms on
many ways, yeah, but we want to
know their worst behavior.
And the worst days, how are they
behaving?
Meaning when the end is very
large for all our program, there
is some input right when that
input is very very large, right?
It is almost tending to Infinity
at that stage.
These lower order terms hardly
matter, and these constants also
hardly matter.
It is that N which will be
dominating right?
So we can drop all that and we
will get some final answer,
right and that is called the
Order of growth, right?
So this is what we had looked at
in the last Class 3 steps,
right?
Whenever a problem is given,
firstly you'll think about it.
You'll write it pseudo code once
we have written it pseudo code
you will see the primitive
operation in each line and you
will note it down.
You will submit it once you
submit it, you will get an
equation right six n + 510 N
plus 20 whatever.
And then that you will ignore
your lower order constant and
you'll also ignore your constant
multipliers.
You will complete that and
finally you will get that answer
and that will always be inside
this right?
It'll be either one either log
N, log N square N cube, or in
between there could be a lot of
things like N power 4 N power
five and power 100.
All that can be there or it can
be of the form to power north or
north factorial right?
Since uh Infinity power four is
Infinity, uh.
Can't we consider N power four
is just N?
No, we cannot do that.
Yeah.
So we are not considering end to
the power Infinity end itself.
We are considering as Infinity
right and we are not considering
an as Infinity.
We are assuming it is that
bigger number.
Yeah, I was just giving an
analogy.
There it is, almost moving
towards Infinity.
It is not Infinity and we are
again not talking about yen
power Infinity, right?
And of course, for any input,
nobody's going to give Infinity
as input, right?
We will not be able to give
Infinity because Infinity is not
quantifiable, right?
This very large number.
So this is what is order of
growth that is, we expect our
algorithms to work faster for
all the values of N, but that is
not true.
Great.
If you see here, this N is
nothing but 12481632 were just
doubling it after 32.
You'll have 64128 and so on.
This is your normal yen.
You're just doubling it.
OK, but what about this login?
When you substitute these N
value in log N, what are you
getting the values you're
getting some values 012 and so
on and then column is again the
same column N log N you are
calculating login value and then
multiplying that with yen so you
are getting this as the values
right?
They're all almost comparable.
They're almost the same, even
with 16.
They're all like, you know, over
1664 and so on.
But suddenly when you have N
square here you see that till
here they were almost in the
same range.
But here, suddenly this has
become a 3 digit number and for
the N cube for here it all
started together, they were all
a single digit number.
They were all comparable.
They're OK, but here it became a
2 digit.
Here it has bombarded already.
Yeah.
So for log in it is just three
whereas N cube is 512 and for 16
it has become 4000.
Whereas if you see two power yen
initially they were all OK,
right?
Two power one was 2/2 power, two
was 4/2 power, four was 16,
whereas 2 power 8 suddenly
became two 58256 and two power
16 is already 65,000 and two
power 32.
You see the number here, right?
So big.
So what do you really mean?
Yeah, when this N value
increases, is it better to have
our final complexities log N?
Something like this?
Or is it better to have N Q2,
power N etcetera?
Yeah.
Real quick.
So I do all this so from this
table, what are we understanding
like log N, log N are these guys
good or are N cube 2 power N
these things good?
Yeah, the left hand sides are
good.
Yeah, because even when North is
increasing, their values are not
drastically increasing.
Where is this N cube 2, power N
factorial, etcetera.
When north is increasing, their
values are rapidly increasing,
right?
So that is what we put it in
this chart or this equation,
that one is very good.
Yeah, irrespective of whatever
input you give, I'll have a
constant complexity, just one,
one constant time.
Then login is better then end is
OK N log N is better N square,
NQ.
These are all OK, so one log N
etcetera are very good in
between whatever we have.
It is moderate and in the
extreme end there's two power N
factor etcetera are very bad.
Yeah.
Because if you give a larger
input, it is going to take, you
know large amount of, you know
computation, right?
That is a problem, right?
And finally you have to put this
in some notation, right?
So that is what is called as an
asymptotic notation.
Yeah, they are just, you know,
languages that allow us to
analyze an algorithm and depict
them, right.
So there are three guys.
One is called bingo.
One is Big Omega and one is big
Theta.
Yeah.
Could you give example?
Yeah, that is what we will look
at today, Rajesh.
Yeah.
So Bigo, bigo, mega, Big Theta
corresponds to two three
different things that we already
learned so.
Big own notation is used to
represent the worst case, right?
We are always interested in the
worst case in simple it is the
measure of the longest amount of
time it could possibly take for
an algorithm to complete.
Right, you are putting an upper
bound.
You are telling that whatever
you give us input, this
algorithm will not take beyond
this time.
Yeah.
What are you gonna upper bound?
Yeah.
So can you get above 100 marks?
Yeah, putting a threshold on
your exam marks.
What is that?
That is nothing but big O,
right?
Maximum you can get 100.
You cannot go beyond that,
right?
Similarly, for every algorithm,
you are putting an upper
threshold or upper bound and
you're telling that this is the
longest amount of time it could
possibly take.
It cannot take above that right.
So if F of North is actually our
time taken by our algorithm,
you're telling that you are
putting an upper bound called CG
of north, and telling our
algorithms time taken will not
go beyond this.
This is the worst case
complexity Big Omega.
It is the best case, right?
Can any algorithm run in zero
time units?
They are real quick.
I'd also seen a couple of
questions.
We will, you know, look at that
once we are done with this deck.
Yeah, we cannot have it right.
So zero time you would never
possible.
There is some amount of
computation definitely needed,
right?
So that time putting it as a
lower bound and I'm telling that
it is the measure of the least
amount of time date, so at least
some amount of time algorithm
will take and that is this least
amount be less than this least
amount.
It cannot run.
At least this much time it will
take and then finally average
complexity is the big Theta.
Yeah.
So you are putting, you know, an
upper bound and lower bound for
your, you know, time taken and
you're telling that it will rain
somewhere in this, you know,
upper bound and lower bound.
So which is that particular
notation that we are going to
use across this course?
Are we going to use best case or
worst case or average case?
Because always we told we are
going to take a very large yen
and we are going to do worst
case analysis.
So when we are doing worst case
analysis, we want this big O
notation, right?
So then finally, what we will do
is we will put it inside this
big O notation, meaning it is a
big O bracket and then whatever
answer you had got after all
that analysis, right, so now we
will just complete that story of
again recapping, I give you a
problem, right, for example this
this question like minimum
element in an array, yeah, you
first write the pseudo code
after writing the pseudo code
line by line, you go ahead and
try to calculate the primitive
operation and then Pranav or
someone had asked in between.
Anyway, you are going to ignore
constant and you know all those
smaller elements at the end.
Then why should I focus on every
line, right?
Why should I carefully do and
then?
Anyway, ignore it.
Yeah, that is because in every
line when you inspect, there
could also be some yen involved
there, right?
Your final rule says you will
only ignore the constant
multiplier and that lower order
term.
But what if there are some other
higher order terms in each line?
Yeah, there are some loops and
so on.
That is why we are carefully
observing them.
We'll look at some examples
across the crows.
You will get that point.
Yeah.
What if there are other yens in
them?
Inside each line.
Yeah, that is why we have to
locate each line, write the
primitive operations, submit
them.
After summarizing it, you know
try to cancel or, you know,
summarize and get a small
equation and what is that?
Whatever we are getting, what is
that called?
Real quick anyone?
Yes.
No, that 6 N plus one or five N
+ 10.
Whatever you're getting at the
end, you are writing the
primitive operations, submitting
it, cancelling them, and what
you are getting is called the
order of growth.
Yeah, you are getting the order
of growth and that order of
growth, you will put it inside
the asymptotic notation, which
is big O notation, right?
So I request you to solve these.
So I saw a lot of people who had
already solved this, but try to,
you know, solve this true or
false also and we will have a
discussion around it in our
canvas.
Yeah.
Is this looking good?
Yes.
No, maybe.
That is all we have discussed so
far, right?
All of you simple stuff.
All that being said, we will
continue this right.
Some asymptotic notation
analogies for you.
Right.
The delivery will be within your
lifetime.
Yeah.
What?
What does this denoting?
Is it big O notation or big
Omega or big Theta?
Or in other words, is it average
case, best case or worst case?
Yeah.
Give importance to this word
within.
Yeah, this is big O notation,
right?
You are putting an upper
threshold.
You're telling within your life
time this will definitely
happen, right?
This big O notation or upper
bound or worst case I can pay
you at least $1.00.
Yeah.
What is this?
Is it worst case or best case or
average case?
Yeah, at least $1.00 LP less
than $1.00.
I'll not.
Yeah, at least $1.00 definitely.
I'll give I can give you more
also.
Yeah, this is big Omega or it is
best case or lower bound.
Best case, at least $1.00 LB the
high today will be 25 degrees
and the low will be 19, so we
are putting a range here.
The moment we are putting range,
we are giving big Theta or
average case.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you simple analogies, we will
always stick to this upper
bound.
So now there is this question
that comes into my mind.
So what does the very large you
know order of growth that we saw
in that chart that we saw and
and log N square and Q and all
that in that what was the very
last thing that we saw N
factorial correct.
And then before that, you also
had your two power N so that is
a very large number, correct go
for any complexity question that
I asked in the exam.
If you just go about writing
that upper bound, yeah.
Are you technically correct by
doing that?
Yeah, no big goal is the worst
case, Rajesh. Yeah.
So whatever algorithm I ask, you
are not analyzing, you're not
using the primitive operation.
Nothing.
You just tell that my complexity
is big off 2 power N factorial.
Yeah, such a big number, right?
Let me just write it here for
you to put a test big off 2
power N factorial.
That is a very, very large
number, right?
And that'll definitely, you
know, contain this within or it
is the worst case.
So any algorithm for that
matter, it's complexity will be
less than that.
And by pure definition of bigot,
you're putting an upper limit.
You're putting an upper limit
that my algorithm will take less
than this time, so technically
by Viggo definition and your
smartness.
Is this correct?
Yeah.
Wait, JAGDISH, why we cannot
give?
Because there's a very large
number, right?
So the whole point of Vigo
notation is that we are putting
an upper limit.
We are telling that whatever you
do, whatever input you give,
this is the maximum possible
time my algorithm will take.
So if you choose a very, very
large you know function like
this two power N factorial or
you know north Power N power N
something like this then
technically your algorithm will
take less than this time
complexity.
So by definition, is this
correct N factorial?
Yeah, it is a factorial rumic.
Yeah, but we will never compare.
Yeah, for both the algorithms.
If I just put that both of them
are taking this much time, yeah.
Cool.
So technically, by definition
this is correct.
Yeah, but it doesn't have, you
know, any practical
significance.
JAGDISH was right.
So if you just put this very,
very large things as you know
your complexity, then you are
not getting any real
significance, right?
But nobody can tell that this is
wrong.
If you write a statement that my
algorithm is taking less than we
go off 2 power N factorial, it
is actually correct because this
is a very large function and
your program might take less
than this.
But who are you fooling by doing
this?
Yeah.
So that is why there is a line
in theoretical computer science
that algorithm analysis must be
as tight as possible.
Yeah, if if there is a function
like this right N power of 4 +
N, cube plus 10 + 200.
So for this, what is the big O
complexity?
Can someone tell me?
They are real quick.
I'm spending a lot of time in
this because I want you to
understand this real, you know.
There is a constant.
Leave it.
This is a lower order term.
Leave it.
This is a lower order term.
Leave it N power four is the you
know, thing.
Order of growth to put this,
this is the answer perfect all
of you are right now.
What if I put in power 100?
Is this also correct?
The Empower 4 is greater than
North Power N Power 100 is
greater than N power four, so
north Power 100 is also correct,
but it is not as tight as
possible, meaning this algorithm
might maximum take N power four
only then why are you putting it
as N power 100, right?
So now you get the knowledge
right for any question that I
ask you in complexity, you can
put a very very large number and
tell this is what the
complexities.
But it is not tight as possible
and that is not the right way to
analyze algorithms, but just by
the definition.
If someone goes if someone gives
big of North Power 10, you
cannot deny the fact it is still
correct, right?
Just no.
Did all of you get this point?
Yes.
No, and a lot of these entrances
right in gate exams and all
that, you know, people get
confused with these type of
questions.
Yeah, you should not get
confused while doing algorithm
analysis.
We should be as tight as
possible, right?
But this is not stopping that if
someone abbrev gives you that
equation and gives that big of
North power under it, then
npower 100 of course has N power
four also right.
So this is also correct.
Cool.
That being said, we will try to
break some myths here.
Yeah.
So there is a simple loop here
which starts from one, goes all
the way till less than or equal
to north I plus.
Plus it has a body which is
going to take some constant
time.
So what will be the worst case
of this?
Yeah.
What will be big off in this
case?
It will be in right?
It executes the end times, so
it'll be some constant into N
constant is, you know cancelled
right.
So what you get is north for
some math levels.
You can also evaluate a loop
like this, right?
You can start from the you know
lower limit and this is your
upper limit.
This is the body of the loop
which is 1 and evaluating this
summation operation is nothing
but upper limit minus lower
limit plus the body.
This got cancelled and N is your
answer.
So there is a single loop like
this.
What is the complexity yen if
you have two like 2 loops like
this, what is the complexity?
Just look at this code.
There is a loop I there is a
loop J within that and then
there is something called as.
Constant time, right?
Yeah, the the point here is that
so that you again come back and
watch the videos, yeah.
Pull this is going to take 10
times and this is going to take
N times.
This is going to take a
constant, so that is nothing but
C into and into N which is CN
square.
You can ignore the constant, so
North Square is your order of
growth.
Put it in Pico.
That is your answer.
Well, all of you got it right.
Very good.
So if there are three loops,
what is the answer?
If there are three loops, nested
loops, one within another within
another.
OK, we'll come back to this.
Yeah.
If there are five loops.
Yeah.
Prem, Zimbra and others.
If there are five loops, OK.
Cool, you're getting the
answers, but we will come to
this.
Yeah.
We will come to this point in a
moment.
Well, let's also look at if L
statements.
Yeah, if there are, if L
statements, then how do you
calculate the worst case
complexity in simple?
What you will do is you will
treat both of the parts as
separate code.
You will try to, you know, get
the complexity of the if
condition.
You will get it for the else
condition and then you will take
whichever is larger.
Yeah, JAGDISH, you wanted me to
go back.
Yeah, real quick.
Yeah.
You had anything or?
Simple stuff.
There is a loop.
There's a loop inside that there
is a constant statement pool.
So far I felt what is the
concept?
You have some if code.
You have some else code if this
if is true this will execute.
Otherwise this will execute.
So what we do is we analyze both
of them and take whichever is
larger.
So in this case this 8th part is
just a constant, just one return
statement is there, whereas in
else part you have some for loop
right which runs for end time.
Then there is some constants
here, right?
So this part is a constant C1.
This part is having a constant
plus constant plus again.
So all this is eliminated.
So this part is when this part
is a constant.
So what can a comment about the
complete complexity out of a
constant and then who's larger
yen?
So I will have it as we go off
yet.
So it feels meaning analyze both
the part and take the largest 1
right?
And now coming to logarithmic
complexity.
Yeah, Rajesh and others were
having, you know, asking them
examples.
We will actually look at this in
the whole course here and there,
but just just to give you some,
you know, motivation towards
what is this login?
Yeah.
How does suddenly login come up
right?
Yeah.
So it'll be this slide you mean,
so don't go to the intricacies
of these things you can do later
also, but the whole point is if
there is if else code.
Yeah.
If also you have to analyze
separately whatever if code is
there else also you have to
analyze and then you'll have to
compare which of them is a
larger complexity right?
That will become your final
answer.
Yeah, makes sense.
Are we in this case it was just
a constant, but here in this
there was a loop, so this was
becoming a yen and then there
were some constants here
constant constant.
So this total became C + C + N
and this was just a constant.
So totally it became, yeah.
No.
What is this login right log
complexity in the chart?
Also there was log N, log N and
all that.
So what is this login?
So an algorithm is big O of log
N that is worst case complexity
is log N if it takes constant
time to cut the problem size by
a fraction, and usually it is by
half.
As an example, let us consider
the following program.
Look at this loop.
It starts from one, it goes all
the way till yen, but I'm not
going each step.
Instead of going each step like
this like you know from one to
3/4 and so on.
What I'm doing is I have I equal
to I into two meaning how is it
going?
How are the steps now this one?
From one I go to two, then
directly I go to four, then I go
to 8, then I go to 1632 right
64128 two 56512 and one.
So I'm doubling it.
So which of them is faster?
Do you feel there is a step
where a kid goes step by step,
step by step till the roof?
There's another grid who's just
jumping and doubling every
steps.
Who will reach the roof first?
Public.
That's exactly log in for you.
Yeah, you cannot get simpler
than this, but simply means in
another angle.
Whenever you cut down the
problem size, you're solving the
problem faster.
Correct.
Meaning you are still reaching
the destination here.
Here also, you're reaching the
destination and this doubling is
not affecting your solution
right?
Is equal to I + 2 will not be.
Again, you know logarithmic
right?
You are still going to, you
know, just skip some steps, but
you are not logarithmic.
Logarithmic, meaning you have to
cut down the problem size by
half.
If you do I + 2, you're just
going to 4681012 and so on.
You're not doubling, but here in
this case from 16 you will go
directly to 30, two 64128 and so
on.
So you are skipping down or
cutting down the problem, right?
Whenever you cut down the
problem size by doing all these
types of you know tricks, then
it simply means that you are in
logarithmic complexity.
Yes, no.
Is it making sense for all of
you?
Double the time cube of two
works.
Yeah.
Then it also works.
Yeah, you.
I can have into three and so on.
Also in that case you are
cutting down the problem by
price and not just half right.
But usually in computing we cut
it down by half or two.
So when will this loop end?
So there is also some small
theory on how you got this log
north right here.
You saw that it was my into two.
And how does that translate to
log in, right?
So that part I've just explained
here, this is not of too much
relevance, but for some math
lovers you can actually, you
know, look at this later,
meaning you can substitute the I
values and you can see when will
this loop end and at that stage
if you just take log both sides
you will get it as log in.
Yeah, it it means log base 2.
Correct E Please repeat once.
Uh, the previous slide, you
mean?
Yeah, I would again urge.
Please spare 200% while in the
class.
Yeah, otherwise will be just
stuck to 1 slide right.
And of course you can always,
you know, go back to the
recordings also.
So if else was a very simple
concept, whatever is in the if
body, right, analyze that right.
Let me just make it simpler.
Just forget this for a minute.
That is, if part there is L part
and at least this separately,
unless this separately, take
whichever is larger.
That is your complexity well.
Not this one.
Which one then group?
Cool.
Let's you know you can watch the
recording and post it in the
discussion if there is
something.
Yeah, but now all of you got
what is logarithmic complexity,
yeah.
Yes.
No, it is as simple as whenever
you cut down the problem size.
Yeah, that that proof is fine.
Yeah. Summit.
Don't worry too much about it.
Whenever you are cutting down
the problem size, it means you
are falling in this bucket of
logarithmic complexity.
Yeah, yeah, that is also valid
notation, correct?
In that case, Rakesh, it is not
taking log N complexity.
It is taking yen times the log N
complexity that is also correct.
There are a lot of algorithms
who take log N log N.
Yeah, we will look at it when
the time comes.
Yeah.
When we analyze some algorithms,
you might come across this as
the final answer.
Yeah.
OK, it's time for you now.
Yeah, there are a couple of
codes now, right.
So you will let me know what is
the time complexity of this.
Yeah, there is a loop within a
loop within a loop and then some
constant.
Yeah, Ncube, a lot of people N
cube, OK.
I'm still hoping for that one
person who will give the correct
answer.
Yeah, we'll be Krishna is right.
And let's see why here I have K
is equal to K into two.
So is this log this thought this
is a constant. This one is log N
and here you have an.
Here you have a.
Yeah, right.
So the complexities yen, square
log north and constant constant
even ignored, right?
It was not N cube because you
should give importance to this
right?
It was not K plus plus it was K
is equal to K into two, meaning
this whole loop is just log in
right?
Yes.
No, all of you got this.
You know the derivations are not
important.
Yeah.
So you just, you know, try to
keep putting your eye values and
at a point when you know you
take log, it will become log in
the other side will just get
cancelled.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
Yeah, that's not important.
Just remember that whenever
you're cutting down a problem
size like this, you are falling
in the bucket of log N cool.
Is this clear?
All of you.
It was not N cube, yeah.
What about this part of code?
Yeah, yeah, that is still N
money content.
The the third part where you're
doing I + + J plus plus that is
what matters, not the middle
part.
Middle part is just comparison.
Yeah, it will not reduce.
Yeah, that is still treated as
yen when in itself is Infinity.
Infinity by half is also
Infinity, right?
N square.
Yeah, a lot of you.
N square.
Yeah, very good.
All of you are wrong, yeah.
Carefully observe this code,
yeah.
There is a constant time that is
just return statement and then
you add this outer loop which is
going to execute and times and
then there is this inner loop
which is having a break
statement.
Yeah.
Do you clearly see this when Jay
is equal to 1?
It will come inside.
It will print a star.
It will break break, meaning it
will come out of this loop
completely.
It will go back to my is equal
to two go for two it will again
go in J will become one again I
again reinitialize is equal to 1
it will print a star it will
again break.
So this for loop is not even
acting as a loop, right?
Every time J will be one
immediately it'll come and print
and you are not going to J equal
to two J, equal to three,
etcetera, because immediately
after this break line I'm coming
out of the loop.
So this loop is not even acting
as a loop.
It is as good as not having this
loop at all and just having this
print correct.
So what is the complexity then?
It is just big off yen, but most
of you had told N Square right
and now I lost you the same
question.
I have 3 loops.
What is the complexity?
I'll.
I'll back.
I'd asked you and a lot of you
told NQ when I had asked about 5
loops.
You all told N Power five.
Yeah.
When someone asks you about, you
know there are three loops.
What is the complexity and so
on?
You should immediately deny it
and ask them.
You show me the code?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, Bharathi.
Same with all of you are right.
Right.
Depends on the code.
A lot of authors still have this
mistake, they just generalized
things, telling that you know if
there are two loops it is N
square.
If it is 5 loop, it is North
power five and so on, which is
absolutely, you know, insane.
It all depends upon the body of
them.
If they have some breaks like
this, or if I, you know, have a
Live loop inside them, right,
what about that right?
Nobody talks about that, right?
If there's a for loop, and if
there's a while loop inside that
for loop, that is also a loop,
right?
So I should not generalize
things, telling that if these
many loops are there, this is
it, and so on.
And if I have continue, break
and all that, it can alter the
flow, right?
So the whole crux of this
exercise, what we did is you
should not come to such way
conclusions.
You should inspect code line by
line and then take an informed
decision as to what is the
complexity.
Was it clear guys for all of
you? Yeah.
Yeah.
2nd Loop also runs.
If this break was not there,
then it would have run then it
it should have run for end.
This would have run for end and
total complexity of drive in
North Square.
So some quick definitions for
you.
Linear complexity.
It is nothing but the ones that
are having the final answer as
yen, quadratic meaning and
square right.
The time taken is proportional
to the square of the input,
meaning N square that is North
Square right should be
complexity N cube and this is
nothing but log N.
Right.
So yes, you know the same word
equivalents to it.
So that you don't get confused,
someone can just tell that I've
analyzed it and my final answer
is cubic complexity.
So what they mean is actually
enqueue, right?
Cool, but now let's also talk
about the type of algorithms,
right?
There are two types, right?
One is iterative and one is
recursion.
Yeah.
Do you have any idea about this?
Why do you write as we go of
North Square rather than only N
square?
Because we are representing time
complexity.
Yeah, when you just write N
square like this, this is not
representing the worst case
behavior, right?
Only when I put it as we go, it
means that in the worst case N
squared is my complexity right?
Is this clear, Amit?
If I just put an answer as this
to FN is equal to North Square,
this means the order of growth
is North Square.
I'm not indicating that worst
case, so only when I put it
inside big or Omega and so on.
I know in what case this N
square is the complexity, so
that is why I'm putting that big
O.
Yeah.
Is it clear for all of you?
Yeah, across the code will be
seeing some examples that if
yeah, so first two classes we
are just, you know, uh, taking
some motivation for this.
Cool.
So in a Broadway we can write
algorithms in two ways.
One is iteration, one is
recursion.
Iteration means you are using
loops, right?
You're using some loops like for
loop while loop and so on,
whereas recursion is another
technique where an algorithm
calls itself or a function calls
itself again and again until
certain criteria is met, right?
That is also another technique.
Yeah.
The process in which a function
calls itself directly or
indirectly is called recursion,
and the corresponding function
is called as a recursive
function, right?
So define a procedure P that is
allowed to make calls to itself,
provided those calls of P are
solving the subproblems of
smaller size, right?
So what are the conditions for
recursive procedure or a
recursive algorithm?
It should always define a base
case and what is the base case
now?
A base case is a small sized
problem which can be solved by
the algorithm directly without
using any recursion.
Yeah, we will see some examples.
Yeah, it will be even more
clear, right.
There are a couple of questions.
Let me just look at that.
Yeah.
So till money content was just
responses because I had a
question N square log N can
can't we neglect log in and take
consideration of North Square
only?
No, no, no.
We should we should not be doing
that.
But technically speaking, yeah,
out of this N square log in.
I mean, if you feel that, you
know, I can just ignore that and
square and just have log in or
ignore that log in and have N
square.
Yeah.
If you had N square plus log N,
you can ignore this and make it
as N square, whereas here it is
multiply right you're telling N
square times log N is your final
complexity right?
If you ignore this, then you are
completely messing it up.
Yeah.
If you had only addition then
you can you know that whole rule
was about ignoring the lower
order term when it is lower
order term, right?
So in this this full thing is
one term.
Yeah, you are actually
dissecting this and trying to,
you know, ignore this, which is
wrong.
Yeah, because you got this.
It was N square plus log N you
could have very well done that.
You can cancel the log and N
square will be the answer,
whereas this is one term itself.
Yeah, you should not do that.
Cool.
So let's take some examples of
this recursion.
Let's go.
Recursive algorithm will look
like this if the problem is
small enough, solve it directly.
Otherwise, break into one or
more smaller subproblems, solve
each problem recursively, right?
Meaning again and again try to
do the same thing.
The requirements of a recursive
solution.
There should be at least one
small case that can be solved
directly and a way of breaking
them right.
One or more smaller sub problems
of the same kind.
We'll take an example at EB
Clear.
We want to find out the length
of a string.
I want to know in a name or you
know how many characters are
there, right?
For example, the same name you
know, because if I take what is
the length of this string?
Yeah, there if I can do it using
a loop also I can start a loop
from the zeroth character.
I can go to first, second and
all I can do all that.
Finally, when I'm done with this
string, I will know that this
was 01234 array indexes start
from zero, so my total length is
5, so I can calculate the length
of the string using loop also.
But if I want to do it using
recursion, how do I do that?
I know a base case that when
there are no strings, it is an
empty string.
What is its size?
Yeah, I have an empty string.
I don't have any string at all.
No character.
Then what is its length?
Zero.
I know that it is a no brainer.
I don't need to do any
calculation or you know any
further breaking it down and so
on.
So that becomes my base case.
I'm telling if this string is
empty, no characters, then
return it as zero.
Otherwise, compute the length of
the string without the first
character, and since we are
neglecting the first character,
we are doing A1 plus.
So what we're trying to do is
try to do the length of 1 plus
length of I .K.S costs and then
again we are telling for cost.
Do we test one plus length of
case and then we are telling one
place ignore the first card
again OnePlus length of a S
again this is 1 + 1 + 1 plus
length of 1 plus yes.
Then it will become 1 + 1 + 1 +
1 plus length of yes.
For that it is 1 plus nothing
for nothing.
You know that that is the base
case that is 0.
So you Add all this.
That is fine.
Yeah.
Is it making sense, guys, all of
you, every time when we went for
recursion we solved the problem
of a slightly smaller length.
Initially, we wanted to know the
length of Vikas, but we trimmed
it down to I .K.S then to .K.S,
then to S, then to S and finally
empty, meaning you hit the base
case and you got the answer.
No, this is broadly Divya.
It falls into these two
categories.
Any algorithm that you know have
a look at it.
Mostly they will fall under
these two categories.
Broad categories only.
Either it will use some looping
paradigms or it will use
recursion.
If you give look at books
software, it will of course use
both of them, right?
Some parts will be looping, some
parts will be recursion and so
on.
Yeah, it's the same example.
I've again given a small, you
know pseudo code type of a thing
and just like Vikas, I have
traced it out using a small
string that AC length of AC is
nothing but one plus length of C
length of C is nothing but one.
Let's you know length of E
length of is nothing but one
plus nothing.
So this is nothing is 0 right?
So it goes back and length of AC
is 3.
Right.
So all of you understood what is
recursion you are breaking down
the problem into smaller sub
size, right?
And every time you are doing
that, you are reaching closer to
the base case.
Once you hit the base case, you
know the answer already, right?
For base case something like
this like 0 and so on.
And then you again, you know, go
back to get the final answer.
Let's take this example of
factorial of a number.
What is factorial of a number?
What is factorial of five?
By factorial is nothing but 5
into 4 into 3 into 2 into one
right normal math.
If you want to calculate
factorial of any number using a
program right, how can I write
an algorithm?
I can write it using both.
I can either use iteration or I
can use recursion.
So this first part is using, So
what is it using?
It is using a loop so it is
iteration.
I'm having a variable.
I'm having a loop right?
I'm doing result equal to result
in two, I here.
Note that I starts from 1,
otherwise the whole answer will
always become zero, right?
It will always be 0, so be
careful.
It starts with one.
It goes all the way till equal
to north, right and you are
doing I equal to is it equal to
into result?
And finally, they're variable
will have your result, meaning
it will have one in two one,
then one into two.
Then you know that 2 into 3,
that's six into, you know, five
and S1.
This is the way to do it using
iteration.
What about recursion?
We're telling when what are the
0 factorial?
Yeah, anyone 0 factorial that is
also one very good.
So this could have been even
better.
I could have returned this code
as when N equal equal to 0 or
when N equal equal to 1 right?
In that case, I know that the
answer is 1 only.
That is my base case, otherwise
I will do 10 into factorial of n
-, 1, right.
But for five you will do
factorial of five into factorial
of four.
For four you will do 4 into
factorial of three.
For three you will do three into
factorial of two.
For two, you'll do you know
factorial of two into one, and
for one again when you want
vector of one you know you have
reached the base case.
The whole answer will be one, so
you will again, you know,
backtrack.
You will substitute one as I
answer, and so on, and finally
you'll get the same 120 it it is
the same answer.
It is the same way, but we have
returned it in the two different
paradigms.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you?
Same problem solving either or
recursion or growth will be
same, yes, correct.
It should be the same, yeah.
Otherwise there is something
wrong, right?
So it should be the same order
of growth.
Cool.
So now let's look at how do you
analyze these two?
If this type of algorithm is
given, how do you analyze if
this type of recursive algorithm
is given?
How do you analyze?
I will look at that and then I
leave you free for the day.
Yeah.
The first part, which is an
iterative algorithm, do you
already know how to analyze it?
Analysis of non recursive
algorithms.
Nonrecursive means what?
Nirmal, what do you mean by non
recursive?
I keep having this.
You know, word place.
Yeah. Iteration.
Yeah, nonrecursive means it is
iteration, right?
There are only two techniques.
One is iteration, one is
recursive.
So nonrecursive means iteration.
So what do you do?
This is the story that you have
already learned.
Yeah, based on the input size,
determine the number of
parameters to consider.
That is your yen.
Identify the basic or primitive
operation in that algorithm.
Check whether the number of
times the basic operation is
executed depends only on the
size of input or are they in
loop? Etcetera.
Try to find that out.
Obtain the total number of times
the basic operation executed.
Simplify using standard formulas
and get the order of growth
right.
This order of growth is nothing
but T of N the time taken for
North you will get some equation
here and you would have applied
those you know the standard
formula, meaning you will apply
normal math formula like for
example if 3N plus N is there
you can make it as 4 N and then
in this foreign what will you
do?
Anyone when I'm trying to do
algorithm analysis, does it?
There's this four matter.
You cancel it.
Four.
I'll make it as.
Yet, right so this process I
will do and I will get that is
my order of growth and then I
will put it inside my asymptotic
notation that you have already
learned right for iterative
algorithms.
Can you read real quick look at
this code and firstly tell me is
this recursive algorithm or
iterative algorithm?
Yeah, that this is the rule,
yeah.
What is the rule?
Count the basic operation.
Look at loops or whatever it is
and try to get the you know
total number using standard
formula.
Simplify it.
Get the order of growth.
Put it in big O notation for
this one.
Can you first tell me?
OK, it is iterative, right?
Because there is a loop here and
there is no function that is
calling itself the same name,
etcetera.
Is not there, right?
Perfect.
So for this iterative algorithm,
all this is just input output.
You know, comments, the actual
code just starts here.
Can you do exactly what we
learned last class?
Yeah.
Yes, we go to others.
There is a four loop you look
at, you know each line, you will
look at.
OK, there is this basic
operation.
There is this basic operation
and it is inside a loop and this
loop there is no break and
other.
So this loop is going to run for
end times, right?
Yeah, real quick.
Yes, NANDAN, time complexity
will be the same, but space wise
there are some, you know
differences.
We will look at it in the next
classes.
Yeah.
When the time comes.
Yeah, very good.
The complexity of this code is
we go off.
Yen.
Correct, because there is this
constant primitive operation.
There is this constant primitive
operation and then that is
inside a loop, right?
A single loop, so it is there is
no break, nothing.
So it is we go off yet in this
problem, the size of the input
is yen and this is the parameter
to be considered.
The statement executed is in
loop and the basic operation is
key is equal to F5, meaning that
comparison which is the constant
which is inside a loop.
So the basic operation is inside
a single loop and hence the
complexity is big off, yeah.
Actually you should have done
this like what we did in the
last class, right?
So every line you will look at,
you know this is going to take
from zero to a, you know, and
minus one there.
There is this line.
This return should have been in
the next line, right?
So you can write it like that.
Simplify it and try to, you
know, cancel and get this
answer.
So if you are given an iterative
algorithm to write, will you be
able to write the seudo code,
calculate the primitive
operations, simplify it and put
it in big O notation?
Will you be able to do this?
Yes.
No, I want all of your responses
real quick.
Yeah, right.
The operation observe the
primitive submit.
It simplify it, put it in big O
notation.
One part of the story is over,
but now if a recursive algorithm
is given, what do you do?
There is a difference if there
is a recursive algorithm given
the same function is being
called again and again, then
there is a question on how many
times it executes and things
like that.
Yeah, yes, yes.
You have to all of you have to
work on these guys.
Yeah.
So every year I get this
feedback that we are talking
with all seems good, but then
I'm confused and things like
that.
That is where all my decks have
problems.
Try to solve them.
Yeah, only when you solve it,
rewatch may recordings again.
It will make more sense and
always feel free to drop an
email or put discussion forum
questions.
Yeah.
Only then the real learning will
happen.
Yeah.
Cool.
So we just learned that for
iterative algorithms it is this,
you know, simple steps you will
be able to do.
But when are there are recursive
algorithms?
It is not very straightforward.
The first few steps are the
same, meaning what you will do
is you will consider the input.
You will identify the basic
operation.
You will see, you know if the
basic operation is executed on,
you know different inputs or you
know how is it.
But after that step, there is a
new thing that is in iterative
algorithms.
What you did after this step you
submitted it, you simplified it.
You applied those you know 2
rules constant and lower order
term and then you put it in big
O notation.
But here you will create a
notation or a relation.
That relation is called as a
recurrence relation with an
initial condition, and then you
will solve this recurrence
relation and once you solve the
recurrence relation you will get
the same order of growth.
Whatever you were always getting
right that equation 2 N plus 56N
plus 10, whatever.
You know North Square plus you
know N + 2 such type of an order
of Ruth.
You will get in that you will
apply those two rules.
Apply that lower order and
constant.
Put it in.
Here we go.
Rotation only addition is you
are going to create something
called as a recurrence relation.
You are going to solve that in
order to get your order of
growth.
Yeah.
Yeah, that we will not be doing,
Krishna.
Yeah.
So that is what I mentioned in
the first class, right?
We are always going to analyze
algorithms in their worst
behavior.
In the worst case, so always we
will be using just big O
notation.
We will not be using Omega or,
you know other notations Theta
and others.
This.
Yeah.
Is that clear?
Initial condition is base case.
That is right.
Yeah.
So you should not go about
analyzing all other cases.
Yeah.
In all our exams, also, if you
find a question like you know,
analyze the time complexity, it
simply means we go, yeah, worst
case only.
Yeah, even if it is not
explicitly told, it is
understood that we are always
going to do worst case analysis.
Yeah, Omega analysis.
Also you can do. Yeah.
Research people do all that for
some cases, but in this course
and then in general practice, we
will always do worst case
analysis.
Cool.
No.
What does this recurrence
relation?
Yeah, so recurrence relation is
when an algorithm contains a
recursive call to itself.
It's a running time.
Can often be described by a
recurrence.
So a recurrence is an equation
or inequality that describes a
function in terms of the value
on smaller inputs.
Yeah, we will see some examples,
but it'll be even more clear.
Yeah, this is a typical example
of a recurrence relation.
Yeah.
Let me first read this out.
Yeah, so don't get panicked the
moment you see equations like
this, there is a way to read
this.
Let me just slowly do it for
you.
Observe it and then we will take
it from there, yeah.
This is a recurrence relation of
some recursive algorithm.
Correct the time taken for the
algorithm with N input is 1 when
your end.
This is 0.
How did I read it?
The algorithms order of growth
or the time taken for yen input
is one or a constant.
When my input is zero, that is
one line.
Second, the time taken for the
same algorithm for end input.
This one plus the time taken for
that same algorithm with n -, 1
as the you know, time taken for
North minus when N is greater
than zero.
Is it making sense there?
Is this recursive algorithm?
When I pause the zero as input
to that, it will take just one
as the time.
But when I pass a number greater
than N, it goes into this
recursive case and that time
it's complexity will be one plus
the time taken for to FN minus
one.
Something like that, correct?
Can you repeat how to read it?
Yeah, I'll do that.
Yeah, the time taken for North
input is 1 when my input size is
0 and the time taken for yen is
1 plus the time taken for n -, 1
when my input is greater than
zero.
Is that clear?
Romik, all of you others, but
this is how you write a
recurrence relation.
Why are we considering base case
as it won't be the case, we will
come there.
Yeah, you cannot.
So can you put this whole thing
inside Virgo notation and tell
this is the complexity for
Andrea?
You cannot do that, right?
Because this is some equation.
Yeah, this is a mathematical
equation.
This is not order of growth
order of growth as we learned.
Should we always there in that
table?
It should either be one or it
should be log in.
It should be N it should be N
log N it should be N square NQN
power 4 something or it should
be 2 power N factor.
It cannot be random.
Things like this right Y n -, 1.
So because for this algorithm it
is like that, yeah.
For each question, it might
vary.
Yeah.
So for some recursive algorithm,
this has been derived.
In this case it is north minus
one.
In some other case, it may be in
May 2 or whatever.
Also, yeah, in this case we are
breaking it down by one each
time.
That is where it is in minus
one.
Yeah, correct.
We are breaking it down correct?
So once you get this, we left to
solve this.
Yeah, we have to solve this and
after solving we will get an
answer right?
And that answer will be the
order of growth.
You will put it inside your big
O notation.
So for solving I need both of
them.
I need the base case also.
I need the recursive case also,
that is why that base case is
also mentioned here. Yeah.
Well, now the question is, how
do you solve this recurrence
relation?
Right, there are three ways to
do it.
I can either use a recursion
tree method or I can do an
iterative substitution method,
or I can use the master's
theorem.
Each of them have their own, you
know, positives and negatives.
We'll take a very quick break
and we'll come back in 5 minutes
and then we'll learn all these
three techniques and then we are
done for today.
I'll still be around, so if you
have any other questions or
something we can chat about
that.
So far so good.
All of you were recursive
algorithms.
You will write the recursive
algorithm.
You cannot just count the
primitive operations, submit it
and simplify it.
So you will create a recurrence
relation like this box after you
create it.
You don't know what to do, so
you'll have to apply some of
these techniques, one of them
and solve it after you solve it,
you will get that order of
growth.
Put it inside your.
Bingo or recursive algorithms.
Will base case always need to be
one?
No, it can be something
different.
Also, this can also be
different.
This can also be different and
here also all the integrity scan
come.
It can change like equal to
north, greater than five,
whatever.
All these are, you know,
modifiable based on your
algorithm.
And now you might have this
question why is he even talking
about all this today, right?
We have not even started
algorithms.
We have not even looked at data
structure.
Why is it directly talking about
all this math stuff, right?
Because at the end of this
class, if you see a recurrence
relation, you will know how to
solve it.
Do you agree?
Because that is what we are
going to learn now.
You will be able to recognize
what is iteration, what is
recursion.
All this you will learn today.
So in further classes and later
part of this semester, whenever
we learn about an algorithm, I
will just create this relation
and I will leave it there.
Yeah, you will know how to solve
this and how to get this final
complexity.
In fact, you would have mastered
by then that in the class itself
you will tell the answer.
Yeah.
Is it making sense guys for all
of you to the first two classes
just is more like, you know,
setting the context for the rest
of the semester, yeah.
Some questions are there.
I completely new to DS stuff
notation, algorithm, data
structure.
Uh, any suggestions that yeah,
so I will, you know, give you 3
steps of suggestions.
First step is attend classes.
Go back and watch these
recordings again and again and
solve the problems in the slide
that is your first step.
All this is the first step.
The second step is go back to
your textbook and read the
relevant topics.
From there, all of these are
there in the book.
Read them right and the third
step is go the extra mile.
Right.
Try to go to the reference book.
Try to solve some you know
additional problems on the
Internet on you know these
topics and so on.
The next question was by combo.
By definition, what is the
difference between order of
growth and asymptotic notation?
Why are we saying calculate
order of growth and put it in
Pico?
Is order of growth not the same
as what we specify in big O
notation?
Yeah, very beautiful question.
It's a very subtle difference,
yeah.
This is annotation and bingo
means that it is worst case and
Omega Theta.
These are notations which denote
you know worst case you know
best case, average case and so
on and what you have there.
In the other hand, and N square,
NQ, whatever you get, this is
your order of growth.
So you need to club these two.
That is, when you can make
complete sense, you can tell
that in my worst case, this is
my complexity in my average
case, this is my complexity,
right?
So that is why we are putting
this order of growth inside the
notation.
Yeah.
Is it making sense? Kamboj.
Yeah, if you just write the
order of growth, then I don't
get the point in which case are
you telling this order of
growth?
Is it in worst case or is it in
best case in which case is this
the answer and we have always
learned only worst case
analysis, meaning that dropping
the constant and all such things
right?
So that is worst case analysis.
So you'll have to tell that in
worst case that is in big O in
worst case.
This is my complexity so that is
why we are putting that inside
the notation in 400 and we are
dropping constant 400 but N log
N ohm you know log in will be
less when compared to N why
can't we drop the login so that
is why right?
I mean, if you see here 400,
this 400 is a constant term
whereas in yen log N there is a
N here also he's also
contributing to this multiply
value right?
So if this was some other
constant number then it is fine.
You can ignore but here this the
there is a end here also.
So you should not, but if it was
N plus log in, you can because
this end is dominating and this
is a plus, right?
This is a separate answer.
This is a separate answer your
adding them there.
It doesn't make sense, but here
this login is multiplied with
this. Yeah.
So you should not.
So can you explain order of
growth in break loop even when
we have break statement inner
loop but still it is getting
executed yen times as outlook
correct.
So when you have a break
statement, only the innermost
loop will be exited.
The outer loop will still run,
so the outer loop complexity was
then that is the final answer.
Vendran hats arrived out.
There are few cases where we
need more than one variable
acting like you're even in even
the even numbers in a range of
yen and do some action on even
numbers.
No, they're also yen is the
total right.
So we need to consider that
only.
Yeah, N + m.
Yeah, that is correct.
Yeah, that is what we have to
do.
That is why there was a line
here that consider all the
inputs right determine the
number of parameters to
consider.
OK, if there are multiple
arguments, multiple inputs
coming to your program, then you
should consider all of them.
Yeah, in quiz there was a
question.
Uh empower four.
Yeah.
We will come back to the
question.
Yeah.
We will come back to the
question I had that is, we also
discussed about that you know in
power four and so on, right.
But Long story short, the answer
is true there correct.
The correct answer should have
been power four, but it has been
written in power 27, but by
going by the definition, you
cannot deny that this is wrong.
You can write it as two, but
when you are doing algorithm and
this you will not do that.
Yeah, you will be doing it as
tight as possible.
He just clear guys, all of you
real quick.
Yeah, it's already passed 940.
Yeah, when we begin.
We have some time in the end we
will again chit chat, yeah.
Well, so let's look at these
three methods.
Yeah.
So assume that there was a
problem given to you and you
have even returned the, you know
pseudo code for it, but you have
returned it using recursion and
then you have translated like
this and now we want to solve
this to get the final answer
right.
So we will try to look at this,
yeah.
Recursive tree method.
So recursive tree method or
recursion tree method is a very
visual method.
It converts the recurrence
relation into a tree and it sums
all the per level cost to get
the total cost of recursion, or
in other words, to get that
order of group.
But still look at this and
answer a couple of questions.
Is this a recursive algorithm or
is this iterative?
And.
Yeah, real quick.
It is recursive right?
Which line is confirming that
which line in this this line one
line two, line three, line four,
line 5?
Which line confirms that this is
a recursive algorithm?
Do not line one line 4 right?
So I have the same name as this
function name.
That is where it is calling
again and again, but it does
smaller input.
Here I'm calling within, but
here I'm calling with a smaller
input than yen.
Right, I've reduced that end and
I have done that very good.
Now, what is the base case here?
Yeah, the base case is not very
evidently written here, but it
is there.
So what is that base case when
in this three it will run when
it is 2 it will run when is,
when is 0, what will happen when
N is 00 greater than zero is
false, so you will not run.
So when N is 0, attached is your
base case in greater than 0 is
not your base case N greater
than 0 means you will do this,
which is what is recursion
recursive case.
When N is exactly equal to zero,
that is your base case.
When you done all of this, did
you get this point?
Yeah.
In other words, like what Gopi
says, it can be and less than or
equal to 0.
The opposite of this will become
your base case, chilienne equal
to 1 not be base case.
No, because it'll run here right
when N is 11, is greater than
zero.
So I'll go print one.
I'll go here.
I'll execute so whenever you
enter into this block, it means
you are in the recursive case,
correct?
No, this is not infinite loop.
No, there is no problems here.
Yeah, this is a recursive
algorithm to print some numbers.
So now let's try to visualize
what's happened.
Let me take N value as three.
Who initially print numbers of
trees being called three is
greater than zero, so I go into
this loop, meaning which case I
am in.
When I go go into this loop, I
mean base case or am I in
recursive case?
Yeah, I'm in recursive case,
right?
So I go ahead and print that
three and then I go print
numbers of 3 -, 1 is 2, so I
call that again.
I go back and with the number 2
who is greater than zero, so
again I'm in recursive case.
I print that number 2 and call
print numbers of one.
I go on top again.
I call it now.
Again, one is greater than zero,
so I print that number one and I
call this function print numbers
of 1 -, 1 which is 0, and now
zero greater than zero is false.
So my algorithm ends there.
Great so far north is equal to
three.
How many levels are here?
1234 What is the base case here?
Base case is N equal to 0,
correct this case when zero is
not greater than zero.
I'll stop my algorithm right?
This particular line actually
has that base case hidden
insight correct, and whenever N
is greater than zero, I will
execute this recursion and then
exactly becomes equal to zero.
I'll stop so N equal equal to 0
is the base case pull so this
how many times have I called
this?
Or you know how many levels are
there?
1234 levels are there in this so
I can write it as this 3 + 1
that is my four.
So this three is nothing but my
yen and this one is a constant.
I can ignore it so my
complexities be go off here.
Did you get this point of how
to, you know, visualize what is
going on in this code and trying
to, you know, get this answer
four time that is end time.
Exactly.
That's right.
Yeah, all of you guys.
Yeah, let's take another example
like this factorial.
So in this case again factorial
is being used with a smaller
input, so it is a recursive
algorithm.
What is the base case here?
You, SURAJ, will answer that.
Yuvraj prakruti others.
Yeah, here it is.
Very explicitly, given N equal
equal to 1, then return 1.
Otherwise, yeah, this return
line is else right?
It is aligned here, so N in two
factorial of North minus one.
So this is the recursive line.
This part is your base, right?
Perfect.
So what happens when I give
factorial of five?
Why is nothing but factorial of
four for four?
It is 4 in two factorial of
three.
I don't know what is factorial
of three answer that is 3 into
vector of two.
For two it is 2 into factorial
of 1, for one it is, for one it
is already known.
Here I have hit the base case.
Yeah.
And now this one is sent back,
so two into one becomes two.
So this two answer is sent back
as this F of two answer.
So 3 into 2 becomes 6, the six
is sent back here, 6 hours are
2424 is sent back, 24 into 5 is
120.
I got the final answer.
So how many levels are there and
in each of them you are just
doing a primitive operation
which is multiply which is 1
unit.
So there is this 12345.
Pawar N is equal to five.
We had five levels.
So what is the complexity?
Off.
Yeah.
Brendan had a question, Sir.
If N is equal to 1 in previous
example, can we just still
ignore one as N equal to 1?
No, you can.
You have to still mention that
as your answer.
Yeah, you have to write it as
yen only because yen is one.
Yeah, but what if N was hundred?
Then your assumption goes for a
task that 100 equal to 1 equal
to C, right?
So whatever is in that is your
complexity.
Yeah, this case, all of you got
it.
Guess no, maybe.
Your real quick guys.
But for so these are all very
small code snippets, right?
So these programs are not even
having more than 510 lines.
But what if a big program is
given which is having recursion?
Yeah, we'll will we be able to
draw such grease for every level
and try to, you know, get the
answers.
Yeah.
Real quick guys, we will not be
able to scale this approach.
Yeah, this is the visual
technique, and you're actually
just crudely drawing the number
of times it is, you know,
calling the recursion and so on.
So this will not be very
scalable only for some small
code snippets we will be able to
use this.
So that is why we have another
method which is called the
iterative substitution method.
So the iterative substitution
method is also known as the
plugin check method.
Substitute the general form of
the recurrence for each
occurrence of the function on
the right hand side.
It is more like mathematical
induction which you might have
studied in your school days with
the hope of applying iterative
substitution that at some point
we will be able to see a pattern
that can be converted into a
general form and then using the
base case we will try to solve
the general form and get the
answer.
Yeah, we'll try to do that.
But before that, let's take that
same code and try to 1st create
a recurrence relation out of it,
right?
30 of north is equal to that one
right.
The time taken for this
algorithm is.
It is what?
So first line should be your
base case.
So any guesses what should go in
the first line?
It will be a constant when my
end is 0 correct.
When I pass this program as zero
then that is my base case right?
Very good.
So it is a constant one or some
authors also prefer to use it as
a constant C or a whatever it is
a constant when my base is 0.
When you give a number greater
than zero, then it is 1 plus
that printing is taking one.
This is one time unit less the
time taken for the recursion,
which is this line right for the
time taken for the rest of the
numbers I don't know, so I'll
write it as time taken for the
rest of the numbers.
In other words, the time taken
to print 5 numbers is 1 plus the
time taken to Bryan 4 numbers.
Something like that.
So now I have translated this
program into a recurrence
relation.
Did all of you get this?
Of course, we'll keep doing this
in the whole course whenever we
write recursive programs, we
will try to convert it like
this.
Mostly that line, which is the
recursion line, will give you
this recursive case, right?
Yes.
No, all of you got this.
Now we are going to solve this
using iterative substitution
method.
But before that, we will try to
look at the basic substitution
method.
Yeah, good old days.
Have you come across these type
of problems in your childhood?
Why equal to two X + 4, three X
+ y is equal to 9.
Now solve it.
Yeah.
What is the value of 1 Apple,
one mango right?
All that right, it is called,
you know, solving a linear, you
know, system of Aggreko
equations.
So what you used to do?
Yeah, you used to bring all of
them in one terms, right?
So why is equal to two X + 4?
So this why you will substitute
it that now all of them are in
terms of X.
You'll try to get that and
substitute.
Take it here.
Take it there.
Cancel get X equal to 1.
Now with this value of 1 you
will put it in any of the
equation for X and try to get
the value of Y right?
This was the normal substitution
method that you would have done
in your school.
Now we are going to do iterative
substitution, right?
There's also you have done this
is called mathematical induction
in school.
Yeah, so this is what was our
question, that is STN is equal
to time taken equal to 1 when it
is a constant you know N 0.
Otherwise it is going to be,
yeah.
1 + 2 and minus one when N is
greater than zero, there's no
all fear with me.
This is not very difficult, but
if you don't pay attention, this
might prove to be costly.
Yeah, so 10 minutes.
We will complete this, yeah.
Whenever we have this equation,
first write the recursive case
and try to start solving.
Yeah.
What is our aim in solving this?
What do we want to get at the
end of this in someone real
quick?
Tell me that I had a recursive
program like this.
I wanted to know it's complexity
we go off, you know something?
I don't know what that is, so I
want to first translate this.
I will now fully solve it and
after solving it I want to get
that order of growth which is N
square in queue whatever and
then that I will put it in my
big O notation and tell that
this is my worst case time
complexity right?
That is my story, right?
So now how do I solve this?
So always start with this type
of a.
The current relation right that
second line recursive line
recursive case started that do
FN is equal to T of n -, 1 + 1
OK.
Right side, I'll have to keep
substituting, right?
Do I know what is the value of T
of n -, 1 they know that.
Your friend, I know that it is 2
of n -, 1 +, 1.
This to F n -, 1 +, 1.
I've just rewritten, but this to
F n -, 1.
I don't know what is the value
of it.
So what is T of N -?
One we don't know.
So keep this equation 1 + t of n
-, 1 S equation one.
OK, be very careful guys.
I'll be very slow, but just be
careful.
Yeah, don't go with others.
You know, chat messages.
It might be, you know, confusing
because they already know it.
Yeah, put N is equal to north
minus one in this equation and
you do that.
What is happening this T of N
becomes for this N you have
substituted it as N minus one.
Think this right hand side for
this yen you are substituting
again in minus one.
So this line becomes to F n -,
1, -, 1 Plus this one.
This is already there, so this N
minus 1 -, 1 we came N minus 2 +
1 right?
So T of North minus one.
Now magically you have got so
this answer can I put it here
instead of this T, n -, 1?
Can I write it as T of n -, 2 +,
1?
Can you do that?
I have done that for this Tom N
-, 1.
I have written a test of North
minus 2 + 1.
There is this plus one already
here.
Correct. Perfect.
So I'll remove this bracket so
it'll be two of North minus 2 +
2.
OK, now the same problem.
I don't know what is the of
north minus two.
So what should I do now?
On the right hand side?
Yes, Robbie.
Yeah.
What doubts you have?
I didn't know what is n -, 1 I
again repeat because this first
part is very important,
otherwise you'll directly get
stuck there.
I didn't know what is this team
of N -? 1.
I put N equal to north minus one
in this equation right in this
first equation I have named it.
This N became N minus one.
This N became N minus one when I
simplified it became N minus 2 +
1 from where N equal to north
minus one because this n -, 1 is
what I want.
I don't know what is the of n -,
1 so I want it so this N minus
one is what I'm putting and this
to FN minus one is directly
there in the question.
This is what I'm going to solve.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you.
So I got this answer.
I substituted it back.
I got this.
I am again stuck in a place
where I don't know what is the
of North minus two.
So for North minus two, I'll
again substitute N equal to
north minus two in this first
equation.
So this left hand side will
become to FN minus two right
will become minus 2 -, 1.
So this is ends, so I'll
substitute it back here when I
substitute this back here.
I'll get you n -, 3 + 1 + 2.
These two again N minus, you
know, three.
So now it is St of North minus 3
+ 3.
Again, the of North minus three
value, I don't know.
I'll put N equal to north minus
three into the equation.
Try to get it.
File will tell me what will be
the next answer.
Yeah, real quick.
What will be the next answer
here?
But you are data scientists or
to be data scientist.
So are you able to see a pattern
here without even doing all
these circles of putting and so
on?
When this was team of North
Minus one, there was a plus one.
There is to FN minus two.
Then it became +2, then from
north minus two became N minus 3
+ 3, so it should become to FN
minus 4 + 4.
Yeah.
Is that right?
All of you?
Yes.
Then it will be that of north
minus 5 + 5, so that will keep
on going right like that.
So till when it'll go, yeah,
somewhere it has to stop, right?
So in general I can tell T of N
is equal to T of north minus K +
K, correct?
So there is a -, 1, there's a +
1 here.
There's a -, 2 + 2 here, minus 3
+ 3, so on, and here it is a T
of north minus K + K there is a
constant K, right?
I can give it as Max whatever
you want.
Yeah, it's a constant.
Yeah. Perfect.
And now when will this algorithm
end?
Any recursive algorithm?
When will that end? Yeah.
Going by our usual definition,
base case.
Correct.
Whenever this becomes equal to
my base case, my algorithm will
end.
So the recursion will end when
the subproblem size reaches the
base case, right?
So here always what are you
doing?
You're doing N minus one then N
minus 2 N minus three.
So you are reducing your problem
size.
You are going towards the base
case, so when this n -, K
becomes your base case, which is
this N equal to 0.
At that time, your algorithm
will stop.
So when north minus K is 0, N is
equal to K so no substitute the
value of K in equation 2 here.
So wherever K is there, you can
put N itself, right?
That was your base case here.
So in sort of this n -, K + K,
I'll write n -, N + N SON minus
N became zero, and this end
remains so T of N is what that
is.
The whole beauty now Surendran
understands why we had returned
this base case also when North
is 0, when you substitute that
here to F0 is the answer is 1.
Correct.
So that one I will write it
here.
That is my base case.
Answer T of zero.
I know when I have zero input,
one is my answer or constant.
I write it here and now.
Can I just ignore that because
it's a, you know, constant or
lower order term, so N is what
remains so I can put it in big O
notation and that is my answer.
Did all of you get this?
Yes. No.
Iterative substitution method.
Yeah, again, repeat, you started
with the recursive case.
You kept on substitute the RHS
like this and hopefully to find
a pattern.
You also found a pattern and you
wrote that pattern out, and then
for a minute you took a pause
and you retrospect it when will
this algorithm end?
This this part this N -, K.
When it reaches the base case at
that time it will end.
So you compare this N minus K
with this base case 0.
So when n -, K, zero, N is equal
to K, right?
This K goes the other side.
So in this equation now wherever
K is there, I'll substitute NI
got the simplification I got the
answer date.
Let's go another problem there
is this, you know substitution
the same, you know factorial
program that we saw earlier.
I write the recursive you know
case of this right?
What are the benefits of using
recursion over iteration?
Not much benefits, but there are
a couple of problems where
recursion is more suitable.
Inherently you are trying to
always divide it and all that,
so it is more suitable.
Yeah, but complexity ways.
It's the same, only that it is
giving right.
So here base case is so are you
able to visualize this part when
if condition is 1, meaning the
base case is 1, then the
complexity is just one right?
You're just having one constant
line, otherwise it is the time
taken for one place though
factorial of n -, 1, that
becomes the time taken for North
minus one when N is greater than
one.
This is a recursive case.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys?
Again, very important to FN is
not actually calculating the
value of factorial, but it is
telling you about the time
complexity, right?
This view of north is nothing
but the time taken or the order
of growth, that value.
Yeah.
Can we solve this?
Yeah, real quick.
I'm not going to do that in the
slide. I have.
A you know a PDF for that.
Let me just open that.
This was written by some TA, so
don't get misled by the you know
and rating. Yeah.
Deal of N is equal to 1 + t of n
-.
One is that the same thing in
the deck.
1 + 2 of n -, 1 and in the base
case it is 1, correct.
It's now all of you are able to
see this PDF.
Call the recurrence equation
using iterative back
substitution.
Yeah.
So there's also called as
backsubstitution.
Some people do prefer it this
way.
I try to substitution method or
I try to back substitution
because you're again and again
substituting backward and using
the base case.
Yeah, the offender is the time
taken to solve the input of size
NT of North minus one is the
time taken to solve the input of
size n -, 1.
So you kept it as equation one.
You substituted N minus one as N
minus.
You know two, then three and so
on.
You founder base case in my
example I had kept it as OK.
Here we have kept a test.
Instead of this three and three,
I have kept a test.
I so the recursion will end when
the subproblem size reaches the
base case, that is when this N
minus I reaches my base case.
Here my base case is actually
one right this part it is 1 here
right?
So I go there, compare them
right?
So when North minus one is equal
to I this I can be taken that
set.
So I you know is nothing but n
-, 1.
So wherever I had I I
substituted that right and again
for those simplify them.
So this I and I get cancelled,
so it is to F1 to FN is nothing
but your base case answer, which
is this one right.
I substituted back this part and
the rest of it already remains
right, so this one and one got
cancelled.
Remaining is yen, so this is
your final answer.
Yeah, all of you got this part.
I'll be uploading this PDF also,
don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, it is the exact same thing
what I did in slide for the
other problem, which is the same
thing, there's no maybe or any
doubts.
Same thing, you're again again
substituting, getting a general
pattern like this, then using
your base case and further
substituting to get your final
answer.
Well, let me open another PDF
for you, which is some other
recurrence relation right.
There is some other recurrent
relation we try to, you know,
keep substituting and you know
with the hope of getting a
general statement, we got the
general statement.
We compared it, but after
comparing when I got that I or K
value, yeah, this is that
example.
Yeah, come with that is an
example here.
So I got I equal to some value
that you know after comparing
with base case I'm again
resuting that in this general
form but after substituting also
I'm getting a lot of
sophistication right?
I have your N plus One North
minus two and so on.
And then this alone is my base
case.
But what about the others?
N + n -, 1 +, n -, 2 up to one.
What does this actually?
Some of Austin numbers correct
in your normal math it is called
the sum of the first N natural
numbers and it is given by a
formula.
It is nothing but yarn into N
plus one by two again N into N
becomes N square plus en user.
You know, further simplify you
get N square as the complexity
right?
But here it was not so trivial.
Right after you substituted
your, you know that constant IR
K value in your.
You know general form.
Again, you had to do a lot of
simplification and then you got
the answer.
And what if someone doesn't know
this part?
If they don't know that the sum
of US 10 numbers is you know
this, then also there is a
problem correct.
Yes.
No, read all of you get this
part.
Yeah, iterative substitution
method start with the recursion.
Keep going.
Find a general pattern.
Use the base case and further
try to simplify and get the
order of growth.
Pull.
Yeah, the NPDF, that is what I
told.
Meaning, after you get the base
case, the simplification is a
little complex.
You need to have some
mathematical you know you should
know that some of the 1st 10
numbers is north into north by N
+ 1 by two right that.
We let me just quickly again
revisit that if it's very
confusing the first part till
here is it clear days you took
your you know base case you kept
on substituting in equal to n -,
1 and equal to north minus 2 N
equal to north minus three.
You kept doing it.
Finally, you got this general
form till here.
Is it clear?
Mavani summit.
All of you?
Yeah.
And after that base general
form, what do you do?
You try to compare your.
You know when this will end?
This end minus N minus one with
your base case you try to get
your I value and try to
substitute it back in your
general form.
You substituted it so this part
alone became one.
The rest of it is, as usual,
right?
Whatever was there is pending.
So you got this line which was
nothing.
But N + n -, 1 + n -, 2 +, n -,
3 up to one and in Max in your
school you would have learned
that the sum of first N numbers.
This is sum of first N number
right 1 + 2 + 3 up to north that
is given by a formula called N
into n + 1 by two.
So you substitute this line with
the formula and now formula
becomes N into north is North
square plus N divided by two.
These are all constant, so North
Square is the dominant term, so
that becomes your answer.
But if you don't know this
connection that you know this is
the formula for having number,
you will get stuck.
Here you will be just be in this
line right?
That is why the next thing comes
where how is I equal to n -, 2?
S again the same thing, guys.
Yeah, I don't know why you are
getting confused.
I'm comparing my base case.
Yeah, that is this n -.
I -, 1 with.
This may base case value one
right.
When this is one my N becomes I
+ 2.
So this one also goes the other
side and my I becomes.
This too goes the other side.
So it is north minus 2.
Yeah.
Is it clear Sagar?
All of you others kamboj try to
practice them.
Yeah.
So I'll upload this PDF also.
It is the same example as we
were doing.
Try to, you know, just, you
know, practice them and then see
the answer.
Yeah.
Well, there were a couple of
questions.
Oops, yeah, so the complexity
will change.
Yeah.
For this question you saw it, it
is North Square for small codes
we use recursion tree.
For large cores we refer
iterative substitution like
this.
When we prefer master.
Yeah, that is what we look at
now here we have N equal to T of
North minus one means we have to
iterate N into N times.
So complexity will be n ^2.
That's right.
Correct.
Yeah.
Cool.
So each of the methods described
above, meaning we have learned
techniques, the recursive tree
method is a very ADOC method,
meaning you are just visualizing
and it's an adhoc method.
It is a little tricky.
You might you know, for bigger
codes you will not be able to do
that.
And this iterative substitution
method is good, but it requires
some mathematical sophistication
in order to solve right?
So in between, you know, we
discussing about that formula,
right?
Some of numbers if you don't
know or you know if you make
some mistakes in that
simplification and all that,
your complexity will become
wrong.
So some amount of mathematical
rigor, you need it.
That is why master's method is
there.
The master's method is like a
cookbook.
It is a utility method for
analyzing recursive relations.
It is useful in many divide and
conquer algorithms.
Forget about this line later in
the semester, we will learn
about this category and then
it'll strike you for you know
why this method is more suited.
But there is a caveat here.
This masters method will only
work when the recurrence
relation is of this format.
Do FN is equal to 8.
This is the recursive case.
Yeah, not the base case.
Yeah, base case is, you know one
not 0.
Whatever we learned, if the
recursive case is is of this
format, eight of north by B + F
of North, where this A is, you
know the size.
Or the number of sub problems
and N is the size of the current
problem.
D is a constant and north by B
is the size of that sub problem
and F of north.
This part is the cost done
outside the recursion, like
addition or all that.
Only if this format matches,
then we can apply master's
theorem.
Otherwise, we cannot apply
master's theorem.
Yeah.
Apply meaning what?
What do we mean, right?
So what is this cookbook?
What do we actually mean by
this?
The master's method for solving
recurrence equations involves
simply writing down the answer
based on whether one of the
three cases applies.
Each case is distinguished by
comparing FN to a special
function N power log A to the
base B.
Yeah.
These are the three cases.
Yeah, small constant epsilon and
all this.
Yeah.
Just take a, you know, a couple
of seconds and let me know if
you want to learn this way or a
simpler way.
So in general, if equation
pattern matches this pattern,
then it means that you can apply
master's theorem.
Then you will look at which case
of Masters theorem you are, and
if one of the cases matches,
you'll take that answer and
directly write it and Masters
theorem alone will always give
you the answer in your Theta
notation.
Leave it there.
Yeah, don't change it to be go
and all that.
Yeah, just if you are playing
Masters theorem, this guy will
always give answer like this and
just use that answer.
Yeah, it is a constant.
Yeah.
So it we learned it here, right?
Be the constant is greater than
or equal to 1 and is a constant.
This late?
Yeah, all of you understood
this.
If there's a small constant
epsilon better than zero such
that F of north is big O of
North power special, you know
log A by B.
So from now on, whenever I talk
about N power log A to the base,
BI will call it as special
function or got function or say
visual function. Whatever.
Yeah, that minus epsilon, then
this answer and then you have
some, you know, constant and so
on.
So do you want to learn this
way?
Or the simpler way real quick,
yeah.
Yeah.
So basically there are three
cases, guys. Yeah.
So the case one characterizes
the situation where F of one is
polynomially smaller than the
special function.
This is called the special
function.
If your F of North is smaller
than this, then you are in case
one case two is A1, where F of N
is asymptotically closer to the
special function, meaning this
first one is smaller, second one
is close to and case 3, where
the F of North is larger than
the special function.
Yeah, so this is exact snippet
from your uh, you know, actual
master's theorem paper.
You want to look at this.
You can also go ahead and do
this, but there is also a
simpler version to it.
Yeah, but apparently what
happened is.
In the Internet you might see a
lot of blogs and other places
calling this as advanced version
of Master's theorem, but which
is not the case.
Yeah, Stence WILP students found
it very difficult.
We actually, you know,
simplified this I had taught it
to some batch like a simplified
form, but I don't know how in in
the Internet in a lot of
websites I see this as you know
advanced version of master's
theorem and all that.
Yeah, but it's exactly the same.
I've just rewritten this
master's theorem to make it more
simple.
Yeah, all of you real quick.
Do you want to learn this?
If you get this one part, then
all of the other master theorem
is simple.
Yeah, real quick, all of you
focus just five minutes.
Yeah, this is the format.
Your friend is equal to AT of N
by B + F of N.
Yeah, and this F of N is nothing
but N power K log power PN.
Well, there are a lot of
constants.
OK, there are three cases.
Yes, one is if this log A to the
base B is greater than K.
If this is the case, then this
is the answer.
Otherwise, if log to the base B
or special function is equal to
K, then there are three sub
cases.
You are in case two and in case
two there are three sub cases
based on the P value.
If P value is greater than minus
one, you are in 2A.
If P is exactly minus one, you
are in 2B.
If P value is less than minus
one, you are in 2C.
Kind of this special function
value is less than K you are in
case 3 and inside case 3 again
based on P value.
If it is greater than or equal
to zero, you are in 3A.
If it is less than zero, you are
in 3.
And make it way simpler for you.
Whenever you get a question
right of this format, if this
format is matching then you will
do four steps.
As simple as that first step you
will carve out the values of a
BA&B second step you will
calculate this answer.
Log it to the base B.
Once you calculate this answer,
in the third step, you'll
compare that with K the moment
you do that, you will get to
know in which case of Masters
theorem you are.
Are you in case one, two or
three?
If you are in two and three,
then you'll also look at the P
value and decide on which actual
sub case you are.
4th step, you'll directly take
the answer and write it.
I'll again repeat it, this is
your question.
Four steps, guys.
All of you.
Just listen to me very
carefully.
200% of your concentration.
Just four steps.
It cannot get simpler than this
first step, just like your
school math, you are comparing
this with your actual equation.
That base case and you know
getting the answer of AB AB that
is your first step.
Second step, calculate the
special function.
Third step, compare the special
function answer in K and decide
on which step you are in in the
Masters theorem 4th step, write
the answer right.
Why we call it as Theta?
Yeah, because the Masters
theorem has been designed it in
such a way.
Yeah, it is by design.
Yeah, the authors have created
in that way.
Yeah, that it will always give
the answer in Theta.
So don't modify that, don't
change it.
There's a lot of history behind
that, so if you are interested,
I'll upload the actual Masters
theorem paper. Yeah.
So the whole literature behind
how they created and all that,
so you can also have a look at
that.
So the point is don't change the
answer if you are applying
Masters theorem, do this, get
the answer and just put it
there.
Leave it there.
Step one for this equation.
What is the value of a BKB when
someone tell me that real quick?
Real quick guys, you'll compare
this with your be of N is equal
to.
ATON, B + N, Power K right.
Please upload the paper on
Master System.
Yeah, I'll do that.
Yeah, in power bar lock power.
Paul, right.
So I'll not show this.
You're going to now compare
this.
Let's do that right.
This school is this a so a value
is to this two is this B so B
values also too.
So I don't know about K&P.
Now I'll have to do that, but
somehow I know that this one is
ilding me this full answer.
When is that possible? Yeah.
Now that is what we are
calculating now.
Yeah, kamboj, that is what we
are.
We are going to calculate lock
power P that P is some constant.
I don't know.
I have to calculate now, but I
know that this full blue colored
circle term is giving me answer
of 1.
When is that possible?
Yeah.
Anything to the power Zero is 1,
correct?
So if I have N to the power 0
into log to the power 0N then
this becomes one into one.
One into one is one.
That is what I have answer here.
So what I can do?
I can do that in PR0.
Yeah.
Yes.
No.
Is this clear?
Yeah.
And always the recursive case is
what will be given here for us.
OK, not the base case.
Whenever we are applying Masters
theorem, only this line will be
given pull perfect all of you
got it.
First step is over.
I have calculated ABN KNP.
I've got the values 2200.
What was the second step?
Yeah.
So we very simple and comparing
this one with this term in power
K log to the power P1.
When is that possible?
N Power K log to the power.
PN when can that be equal to 1
only when K0P0 right?
Because anything to a power 0
right log to the power, 0P
becomes one into one that is 1.
So I declare that K&P values
are zero and I stood right.
Go first step is over.
What is second step guys?
What step is carving out a BKB?
Second step is calculating the
special function.
You cannot directly decide the
choice right.
You have to calculate the
special function or got function
which is always log to the base
B you have calculators even in
the exam there will be a
built-in calculator.
You can put log 2 to the base
two, which is one well third
step, deciding which case of
Masters theorem you are in.
So here in this case my special
function answer is 1 and K
answer is 0.
So special function log into the
base B is greater than K which
means which case of master's
theorem I'm in.
Yeah, I am in case one of
Masters theorem does, case one
have any sub cases case one
doesn't have?
Yeah.
So we know, yeah, log to the
base if it is less than K you
are in 3rd.
Otherwise, if it is greater
you're in first case case one
doesn't have any subcase, so
from simplified master's theorem
case one this is your answer.
So instead of this log to the
base B which you calculated
which was one here right second
step put that here and that is
your final answer that no, no
problem.
Don't be sorry.
Yeah, we'll keep doing that,
Amit.
Yeah, you'll get it.
Yeah, we'll keep doing that.
You will get it.
We are going to do a lot of the
same problems.
That's the example.
All of you clear.
Let's go to the second you'll
get it.
Uh, yeah.
First step you will do now Meet.
Then all of you others try to
get me the values of a BKB.
Yeah.
Yeah, Meet.
Yeah.
First try to get me the values
of A&B at least here.
This case AT of N by B less in
power K log to the power P and
try to get me no answer here.
A values this tool B values this
too, so very straightforward
A&B value I've carved out
and kept.
Let's be very careful, Amit.
Listen to me very carefully now.
We don't know what is scan P
value.
How do we get it?
We'll have to get it somehow,
right?
So let's try to get him.
So this pattern is what we are
following.
But this yen and this is the
same, correct?
That is what this has yielded
you this result, and this is the
Radio 2.
This is Hilda, 2.
Correct.
So far so good, Amit.
I'll keep asking you and all of
this.
Of course, don't mind about it.
Yeah, you're comparing these two
equations.
They're ideally the same, only
correct?
So a value you got to test 2B
value got to test 2.
This full term has given you N
meaning end to the power K log
to the power PN has given you
the answer as one.
And when is that possible?
Meaning, just observe this very
clearly.
This whole log term is not there
in this then answer.
Correct, it is not there.
So when is that possible?
When this P is 0, when this P0
locked to the power zero
anything to the power zero is
one wait, so that log term has
vanished and here N term is
there, meaning 1 correct N to
the four one is 1.
So here it is in power one.
Here it is in power 1N power one
into one is YN only.
That is, what is my final
answer?
So can I call case one and P0?
How much did you get this?
You're just closely comparing
and trying to get your AB KNP
values.
Log term was not there right?
Please read the what do you mean
read the.
OK, let's go ahead.
You we'll keep doing and then
you know you will get it.
Otherwise, I'll invite you at
the end.
Yeah.
So the others, what about all
others?
You got the values of a BKP.
What is the next step?
Calculate the special function.
Yeah, yeah, this is.
This is the you know 2A when
special function value and value
are equal then there are three
sub cases possible right 2A2B2C
and two ways nothing but when P
value right so from Step 2 log
to the base B is equal to K so
you are in case 2 But you don't
know which sub case you are.
So who will help us decide that?
Yeah, real quick guys.
Who will help us decide P value?
So in my case, who is P value?
P value 0.
So P value is greater than minus
one, right?
That is what your master's
theorem told.
If you go back, this is your
slide the go to slide right
special function is greater than
K you are in case 1 equal to
then you come back and look at P
and minus ones right.
In my case this is 0.
If you read, please read your
friend second line my doubt will
be clear.
OK, let me do that.
This one you mean this line?
Yeah, let's, you know, clear if
P is greater than minus one,
then to FN is equal to Theta of
North power K log to the power P
+ 1 N that is, what is the
second line?
So you are in case 2IN case two
you compare P and my P value is
nothing but zero, so zero is
greater than minus one.
So you're in case 2A, right?
What did they say?
This is what it told so instead
of this K put your answer K as
one instead of P put your answer
as zero.
Wait, we should answer is 00
plus one is just one and one is
just one.
So it is 1 into log in this one.
Also you need not write actually
understood, so you got the
answer.
Is this clear guys for all of
you?
Yeah.
So end to the power K and log to
the power P + 1.
I'm not able to understand.
So what are you exactly not able
to understand?
Power means exactly power.
Yeah, just like your in North
Square.
This two something like that.
I've written N power K yeah.
Is it clear?
Yeah.
I I will pause you.
We will come back there.
Let's proceed and I'm not
exactly understanding what you
mean by what you didn't get 10
to the power K means N square N,
power 5.
Whatever this K can be any
value.
Yeah, cool.
In this question real quick, you
guys will carve out what is a
BK&B and tell me.
Remember that this is N divided
by log N yeah.
So no, Step 2 and so one.
I'm just asking you, what is a
BK PA2B2N term is there so it is
having it is not N squared or
North Power 10 nothing is there
means it is 1 right N power one
is north so K is 1 and very
good.
Someone told P is minus one,
meaning when you have N divided
by log N it is nothing but equal
to writing N into log to the
power minus one it when it goes
above it goes in minus.
So my P value is minus.
I'll have to now calculate my
special function log into the
base B I've calculated then the
values I'll have to compare.
I'll compare this special
function and key.
It is exactly same, so I'm in
case 2 right when I'm in case
two.
Who will help me decide?
I'm in two way to be or 2C will
help me do that.
P value.
So here P value is minus one.
It's exactly equal to minus one,
which is made 2B.
So I'm in 2B.
Take the answer instead of K put
the answer as you know your K
value which is 1.
So you are end in to log log in.
This is your answer, right?
Hope is minus one here we
calculate it right when we
carved out your login, went on
top so it had a PS minus one.
What about this question?
What is a BKP real quick N BR28N
term is there but it doesn't
have a Squire 10 or whatever.
So it just has nothing.
So N has the power of 1.
What about this term log has a
power which is nothing but P so
this is 2, whereas this is in
divided by term.
So I SP2 or minus two he is
minus 2.
Very good.
So I have my a BKP value.
I'll calculate my special
function.
That's exactly equal to K, so
I'm in case 2, But I don't know.
I'm in two A to be or 2C, so who
will help me?
P value P is minus 2 which is
less than minus one.
So I'm in case 2C, so 2C answer
just told me it is empower K so
my K in this case is 1.
So I just put a test.
Simple stuff.
What about this?
Who can tell me what is a BKB?
Amit, keep trying.
Yeah, don't lose hope.
Is 4B2 what is K&P here?
Yeah.
Is 4BS2 yeah.
Case this three the power of N
is called K, right?
Whatever is there on top of, you
know.
Yeah, very good.
Yeah, case 3, what is P?
If P is 0, then this whole term
will not be there, correct?
Because anything, the power is 0
log would have not been there
but here log term is there so it
has a power here.
So P is here.
What is that power?
It is 1 correct.
Very good.
He is one.
He got a BKP values.
You will then calculate as a
second second step your special
function, log A to the base B
log 4 to the base two is 2K,
value was three.
You compared them so in this
case the special function value
is less than K, so it'll be then
it means you are in case 3IN
case 3.
Again, there are two subcases.
Again, who will help me?
P value will help me decide.
I mean, three or three BP value
here is 1 and that is greater
than zero, right?
So I go to simplified Masters
theorem 3A, case 3A.
Case told me this is the answer.
So instead of Ki, put my current
three and Pi put my one.
So my answer is Ncube login.
Right.
Another example for you real
quick.
What is a, B. KB?
Ah, practically, it is always
possible to write your forth
with the second term as uh.
This.
Yes, sometimes it will not be.
I will show you is 2B2 case two
and B is is it P is equal to two
get full minus two right ABP
values we already got it
calculate the special function
compare it with K this is 1 this
is 2 so one is less than two.
So you're in case three.
You don't know.
Are you in three or 3B, right,
so will help you be value be in
this case is negative.
It is less than zero, so you are
in 3B right?
The answer and you are done
right.
How P is equal to minus two?
Because here if you see there is
a log isn't division term right?
Oops.
So if you see here, this is
something like return like this.
This should be written as N
square into log to the power
minus 2 N these two are exactly
the same, yeah, since division
it is written here no.
So if this became minus.
Yeah, it's no, all of you
understood this, Amit, did you
also finally understand?
Yeah, very simple stuff.
Yeah, the simplified master
theorem will save you just four
steps.
Carve out a BKB carefully.
After that, calculate the
special function log to the base
B third step, compare that with
K either it will be less than or
greater than or equal to.
If you are less than then you
are in three.
If it is exactly equal, you are
in case two greater than case
one or case 3 and case two you
don't know if you are in sub
cases so you will have to go
back to your P value and
determine that.
Sir, please write the expression
once again with expression.
Yeah, it is just division guys.
Yeah, you can go back to the
recording.
You'll be able to pass it.
It's just division right here.
Yeah, maybe the slide is
confusing.
It's just N square by this.
Yeah, they've given it here.
Everything is.
Well, so there is this last
deck.
This alone will complete.
Yeah.
So I told you that master's
theorem cannot be used always,
right?
That is because in this term,
can you do something like sign
in, right?
What is a?
What is B?
What is SK?
What is BI?
Don't know what is this line.
I know AB, but what is this
statement right?
This FN is not a polynomial.
N itself is a power.
Then what is the power of that?
I don't know.
So what is P?
We don't know, right?
So when you have equations like
this, you cannot use master's
theory.
It's no case.
Are you all getting?
Yeah.
Yes, no.
So when N is equal to some, you
know sign which is not following
that pattern or something like
this, then we cannot use you
know master's theorem we'll have
to go back to our usual case of
substitution method.
Why do we need to learn all
three methods, Sir?
One and two are OK, as you told
uh method one for simple and why
do we need?
Yeah.
So method two is a very robust
method substitution method, but
you need to have some
mathematical knowledge in some
cases and case 3 is very simple,
right?
You just do four steps.
You are able to solve them for
this log, log N and so on.
We learned right?
If you have actually done
substitution method for this
equation, you'd have spent pages
together to get to the final
answer.
But here carve out calculate
special function compare and get
the right case.
Put the answer cannot get
simpler, right?
That is where we learn the
master's theorem.
Also, there are a lot of
excises.
Try to give the recursive
solution for these solve it.
Yeah, I'll be uploading a
practice sheet, a Python
notebook.
You can just feel free to, you
know, play around with it.
It's all related to what we
learned in, you know, order of
growth solve these two equations
using substitution method.
Yeah.
And for all these prior to apply
the Masters theorem right?
Meaning take a BKP values and
try to do all that.
Yeah, you all do this.
Yeah, all these examples Nirmal
are from recursive algorithm
only.
This equation that we have got
is from a recursive program,
yeah.
That being said, that's pretty
much I had for you.
Uh, another important
announcement I had.
So the next week we don't have
a, you know, data structure,
class one in class.
So I will.
I'm not available.
Mostly I don't like to do this.
I don't cancel my classes, but
before even your semester
started this was planned.
Maybe in September or so, I have
some conferences and other, you
know, duties.
So I'm not available next
weekend, so we will not have a
class next weekend.
You'll be free.
I'll get it rescheduled.
And that class compensation, we
will have some time later.
Yeah, some time on the next
Sunday or sometime later.
Cool.
Let me just stop the recording.